here it is Deuteronomy
10:16 Deuteronomy
10:16 okay here you
go circumcise therefore the foreskin of
your heart and be no more stiff neck you
see what physical circumcision pointed
to it pointed
to the greater
reality of the need to have your inner
person your spirit your soul your minds
your hearts
circumcised spiritually by having that
evil
inclination those evil desires sin cut
off from you internally inwardly
spiritually you see
it so physical circumcision the cutting
off of the foreskin the forkin
represented Sin Sin residing in our
members sin affecting
us netically affecting us psycholog
ically spiritually soly physically
needing that to be cut off from us so
now we can be
totally sold out enslaved to God and
righteousness okay you see that that's
deom 1016 okay well I got some more
Deuteronomy
30:6 Deuteronomy 30
verse6 watch here now watch how it
points to Jesus and then we're going to
wrap it up Deuteronomy 30:6 we'll talk
about pigs in part three Lord
delling and the Lord Jehovah thy God
will circumcise thine heart catch it he
will circumcise your heart and the heart
of your seed thy seed why to cut off
that evil foreskin of sin those sinful
thoughts and inclinations why because
then you'll be enabl to love the Lord
thy god Jehovah with all thine heart
with all thy soul that thou mayest live
so you don't sin and die
all right what about Jeremiah
4:4 Jeremiah 4:4 watch
here here you
go Jeremiah
4:4 circumcise yourselves to Jehovah and
take away the foreskins of your heart ye
men of Judah inhabitants of Jerusalem
lest my
Fury come forth like fire and burn that
none can quench it because of the evil
of your doing
okay now watch here guys how it's going
to be so beautiful that if you haven't
heard me discuss this it's going to blow
you away and if you have heard me
discuss it it should still blow you
away Romans 2:
26-29 Romans 2
26-29 watch
here Paul speaking a Jew of Jews a
Hebrew of Hebrews a Pharisee Tau by
gam therefore if the
uncircumcision meaning the Gentile the
ethnic Gentile is not required to get
physically circumcised keep the
righteousness of the law does what is
morally right shall not his C uncircum
uncircumcision be counted for
circumcision see what Paul is saying so
what you Jews are circumcised physically
if you're immoral and you break the law
your circumcision won't do you anything
and you know that Gentile over there
who's not circumcised physically if he
keeps the law and is morally upright and
fears the god of is
won't god consider him to be un to be
circumcised you catch
it and shall not the uncircumcision
which is by nature meaning that he
wasn't physically circumcised if it
fulfilled the law if he keeps the law
the moral
law judge you judge thee
right who by the letter and circumcision
does transgress the law so what you're
physically circumcised Jew if you break
the letter of the law and fail to obey
God's moral requirements you're
condemned but that Gentile who's not
circumcised physically if he keeps the
moral law and fears the god of Israel he
is saved and God will view him as being
truly circumcised unlike
you why Paul why would you say that
because look what he says Romans 2:
28-29 for he is not a Jew this is Paul a
Jew you who accuse us of being
anti-semantic or replacement theolog
he is not a Jew which is one outwardly
who cares you're an ethnic Jew that
doesn't make you a true Jew who cares if
you're physical relatives of Christ that
doesn't make you a true brother and
sister of Christ Christ said the ones
who do the will of my father neither is
that
circumcision which is out in the flesh
that's not true circumcision the
physical that's not true
circumcision so what is true
circumcision what is a true Jew Paul but
he is a Jew which is one inwardly Solly
spiritually psychologically emotionally
and circumcision is that of the heart in
the spirit not in the letter not
according to the letter where you get
physically circumcised where the Holy
Spirit circumcises you inwardly and your
praise is not of
men you don't get praised by the Jews
will praise you if you get physically
circumcised but your praise is from God
who praises you for being spiritually
circumcised okay hold on now Philippians
3:3 so you see where I'm going with
this Philippians
3:3 who are the true circumcision Paul
Philippians
3:3 watch here guys Philippians 3:3 Paul
a Jew for we we who Believers in Jesus
Christ baptized in Jesus Christ United
to Christ by the Holy Spirit we are the
circumcision not the Jews who don't
believe which worship God in the spirit
now literally the Greek doesn't say that
it says which worship the spirit of God
you know how you know you are truly
circumcised when you worship give L to
the spirit of God the literal Greek is
we who the spirit of God worship proving
the holy spirit is God because Holy
Spirit receives
L okay for we are the circumcision and
how do we know we are circumcised when
we worship the spirit of God when the
spirit of God is worshiped by us that's
how we
know we are the true circumcision and
another sign that we are true
circumcision that we Rejoice that we
belong to Christ and rejoice in Christ
Jesus meaning our boast our pride our
joy our happiness is that we are in love
with Jesus United to Christ one with
Christ in fellowship with Christ and
belong to Christ that's our rejoicing I
Rejoice that Jesus is in love with me
and I'm In Love With Jesus and I belong
to him that's a sign that you're truly
circumcised and we don't take no
confidence in the flesh so what you're
physically circumcised you understand
this point is making
sense so how do we
know that we are truly circumcised
inwardly spiritually we know it this way
we worship the spirit of God the literal
Greek is we who the spirit of God
worship and the Greek word for worship
is l l latria is the worship that Jesus
said can be given only to God so how do
you know that you're circumcised when
you worship the holy spirit is God when
you give to the spirit of God worship L
worship that only God can receive that's
the Little
Greek and you boast and rejoice that you
belong to Jesus that you're excited and
you're elated that Jesus loves me and
he's in love with me and I'm In Love
With Jesus and I belong to Jesus and I
live for Jesus that's how you
know that's what Paul is
saying you caught it okay well how and
when do we get this
circumcision how and when do we get this
circumcision well here you go Colossians
21-13 Colossians 2
11-13 Colossians 2
11-13 in whom in Union with because of
Jesus and your faith in Jesus and you
being united to Jesus also ye are
circumcised with the circumcision made
without hands not physical hands
physically circumcising you being
circumcised spiritually when you are
united to Jesus by the Holy Spirit and
putting off the body of the sins of the
flesh by the circumcision of Christ when
Christ performs spiritual Circ surgery
spiritual circumcision on you the moment
you trust in him and were baptized for
infants it begins at water baptism for
converts when they turn to Christ and
get baptized because how do I know
buried with him in
baptism wherein also you are risen with
him through the
faith of the operation of God who hath
raised them from the
dead and then here's verse 13 now I'm
going to tie it with Jesus
verse 13 and we're going to wrap it
up and you being dead in your sins and
the uncircumcision of your flesh when
you were dead and
uncircumcised he hath he quickened he
made you alive with Christ in Union with
Christ when you're baptized and United
to Christ by the spirit having forgiven
you all trespasses now do you understand
now what circumcision pointed to let's
see if you got it
physical circumcision pointed to being
made a new creation in Christ where by
our Union in Christ United to
Christ at baptism the spirit makes you
alive
spiritually cuts off the power and
influence of sin in your life and
energizes you to overcome sin and submit
to Christ being transformed daily from
glory to glory to be more like Christ
until you achieve ultimate glorification
or theosis and are made morally
Incorruptible and physically immortal
like Christ is because that's the goal
being a new creation but now who ushered
the new creation who brought in that new
creation of a redeemed restored Humanity
made morly Incorruptible and physically
Immortal who ushered it in who
started began this new creation of a
restored Humanity being transformed and
restored to become morally Incorruptible
and physically Immortal who ushered that
in who brought that to pass and made it
a
reality who did
that do you do you do you need to guess
I'm going to give you the
references we're not going to quote them
I'm going to give them to you 1
Corinthians 15
20 to
23 45 to
Jesus when Jesus died he died the death
we deserve but then he was raised in his
physical body of flesh flesh and he then
immortalized his
Humanity glorified his Humanity making
his human nature and the physical body
morally Incorruptible he was always
morally Incorruptible don't get me wrong
he could never sin what I'm saying is
when he raised his flesh his physical
body flesh when he raised his Humanity
that act made Humanity Immortal
Incorruptible and he did that as the
first fruits as the head of the new
creation the church so who ushered in
spiritual circumcision who ushered in
this new creation who ushered
this redeemed Humanity being restored
having that sin cut
off being made
Immortal morally Incorruptible
physically Immortal what we call theosis
the glorification deification of our
Humanity in Christ Jesus
did that's why it says when you're
baptized you're baptized into Christ's
death and when you come out of the
Waters of baptism you're being raised to
New Life
being made a new creation like Christ
was raised Romans 63-10 let's quote it
so you can wrap it up Romans 6 3 to
3-10 okay here let me let me show it to
you I don't want to be too loud because
my neighbors is getting UPS sorry
neighbors forgive me it's part of my
daily work Romans 63 to10 watch here so
we can wrap it up because now you're
going to see why eth day and we're going
to wrap it up Romans 6 3-10 King James
Version
know ye not that so many of us as were
baptized into Jesus Christ were baptized
into his death immersed in the waters
and come out buried and raised therefore
we are buried with him by baptism into
death that like as Christ was raised up
from the
dead by the glory of the father even so
we also should walk in newness of Life
did you catch it newness of Life a new
creation that old man that old sinful
Sam buried crucified dead and a new Sam
raised in his place like Christ was
raised for if we have been planted
together in the likeness of his death we
shall also be we sh we shall be also in
the likeness of his
resurrection knowing this that our old
man our sinful selves are uncircumcised
Hearts crucified with him
that the body of sin might be destroyed
when it was buried in baptism that
henceforth we should not serve sin we're
not a slave to sin anymore for he that
is dead is freed from sin so when we
were buried we died to sin now raised
new to live for God now watch this now
if we be dead with Christ see we died
with Christ in baptism we believe that
we shall also live with him because if
Christ has been raised then we're raised
to live with him forever knowing that
Christ being raised from to that dieth
no more death had no more dominion over
him for in that he died he died unto sin
once only one time he died but in that
he liveth he now liveth unto God he
lived towards God in perfect submission
to the father inseparably United to the
Father which is our goal in him theosis
glorification okay so now let me ask the
question so you can wrap it
up who who ushered in this new
creation who ushered in this spiritual
circumcision human beings being
spiritually circumcised restored made
new so they die to sin and live unto God
perfectly forever being made morally
Incorruptible physically Immortal who
ushered it in who began
it Jesus when did he begin it when did
Jesus usher in the new creation
on the third day when he rose from the
dead right but now guys get ready to be
blown away why circumcision on day eight
day because Jesus Christ was raised on
the third day which was Sunday the first
day of the week which was the day after
the Sabbath so he was raised on the
Eighth Day Jesus ushered in spiritual
circumcision on the eighth day which is
the first day of a new creation because
it was Sunday Sunday being the first day
of the week being the eth day the day
after the Sabbath so Jesus was raised on
Sunday ushering in spiritual
circumcision on the eighth day which was
the first day of a new creation that's
why there you go